un nuevo centro de acogida de migrantes
Abre en Nueva York cuenta con unas 500
camas y sus instalaciones en tiendas de
campaña gigantes incluyen lavandería
alimentación y llamadas internacionales
con este centro de la ciudad pretende
sembrar un precedente en el trato a los
migrantes
Este es un momento histórico no hemos
visto algo así en la ciudad de Nueva
York durante casi un siglo espero que la
conclusión de todos ustedes sea que la
ciudad de Nueva York que está haciendo
todo lo posible para asegurarse de que
lo solicitantes de asilo sean tratados
bien con dignidad y que su bienestar sea
lo primero y más importante el espacio
solo acogerá a Hombres solteros y los
albergará durante unos días mientras se
finalizan sus trámites o son enviados a
otras partes del país no hay límite para
el tiempo que las personas que buscan
asilo podrán permanecer en esta
instalación si podemos identificar A
dónde quiere ir la persona es llevarla
allí lo más rápido posible el centro ha
sido criticado especialmente por su
localización en una zona de difícil
acceso y son fuertes vientos que pueden
suponer unas difíciles condiciones para
los migrantes en invierno la apertura
del centro humanitario en randalls
Island se da en un momento de crisis
migratoria en la ciudad de Nueva York
después de que Estado Sureño
republicanos lleven meses enviando
autobuses llenos de migrantes desde la
frontera Sur esta afluencia ha puesto a
prueba la ciudad y llegó al alcalde
ericadams a declarar el estado de
emergencia a inicios de mes